Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, the final episode, Episode Nine: Dogme 95, and Danish film and TV today.
Four directors, one manifesto.
Dogme 95 was a manifesto which the directors Lars von Trier, born 1956, and Thomas Vinterberg, born 1969, in 1995 wrote together with Søren Kragh-Jacobsen, born 1947, and Kristian Levring, born 1957.
The four "dogme brothers" committed themselves to making simple films with focus on the good story rather than technical effects.
Dogme 95 caused a stir, and several dogme films became big successes with both audiences and critics in Denmark and abroad.
Lars von Trier's first dogme film was Idioterne, "The Idiots", from 1998, which is about a group of adults who want to provoke their surroundings and fulfil themselves by playing "idiots", that is, mentally disabled people.
The film reveals in a humorous and tragic way both the group's self-absorption and the surroundings' lack of tolerance.
Lars von Trier also won, in 2000, the Palme d'Or, Den Gyldne Palme, for the musical film Dancer in the Dark, from 2000, which had the Icelandic singer Björk in the lead role.
Thomas Vinterberg's family drama Festen, "The Celebration", from 1998, won the jury's special prize, Prix du Jury, at the film festival in Cannes in France in 1998, while another of his films, Druk, "Another Round", from 2020, won an Oscar in 2021.
In Druk, four upper secondary school teachers try to make themselves and their lives more exciting by drinking, so that they have alcohol in their blood all day.
It goes well in the beginning, but gradually it gets out of control and ends in a tragic accident.
But it is also a film about letting go of control in one's life, waking up, feeling life, starting to live again, and what consequences that can have.
The accident in the film is, for Thomas Vinterberg, a consequence of feeling life.
The directors Gabriel Axel, who lived from 1918 to 2014, Bille August and Susanne Bier, born 1960, have also received international recognition.
Gabriel Axel won, as the first Danish director, an Oscar for the film version of Karen Blixen's story Babettes Gæstebud, "Babette's Feast", from 1987, in 1988, about how a strict Christian congregation, which denies the good things of life, one day is served a lavish meal and therefore suddenly becomes happier and better people.
Bille August won both an Oscar and the Palmes d'Or for the film Pelle Erobreren, from 1987.
The film is based on Martin Andersen Nexø's world-famous novel from the beginning of the 20th century.
Susanne Bier has won both an Oscar and a Golden Globe for Hævnen, "In a Better World", from 2010, which focuses on in which situations in life it is respectively right and wrong to take revenge on others.
One of the 21st century's most prominent actors is Mads Mikkelsen, born 1965.
Mads Mikkelsen received the award for best male actor at the Cannes Film Festival in 2012 for the role in Jagten, "The Hunt", from 2012, as the teaching assistant Lucas, who is falsely accused of paedophilia.
He is ostracised by everyone in the village, and soon he has neither work, friends, girlfriend nor son.
In addition he plays one of the four upper secondary school teachers in Druk, where the uninspiring, insecure and unengaged history teacher Martin wakes up beyond recognition once he gets alcohol in his body.
He regains his joy in work and with it also the self-confidence that anew engages and motivates the pupils' interest in the subject.
Mads Mikkelsen has also had roles in big foreign films, including the James Bond film Casino Royale from 2006.
Here Mads Mikkelsen is James Bond's main opponent, who is in the end shot and killed by a terrorist, who is played by the Danish Jesper Christensen, born 1948.
Jesper Christensen by the way had the lead role as the alcoholic Kaj in the film Bænken, "The Bench", from 2000, which is a portrait of Denmark's socially burdened environments.
Kaj has been on cash benefit for many years, consistently neglects the municipality's activation offers and spends most of the day's hours on a bench in a social housing estate in a Copenhagen suburb in the company of lots of beer, spirits, cigarettes and the neighbourhood's other alcoholics.
Kaj has a daughter whom he has not seen for 20 years, and when she one day by chance moves into the building, he suddenly stands face to face with his past, his lack of sense of responsibility and his wasted life.
In Drabet, literally "The Killing", which is not the TV series, from 2005, which is one of two sequels to Bænken, Jesper Christensen plays an upper secondary school teacher who, because of erotic feelings for a former pupil, loses his moral judgement when the pupil commits a murder of a police officer in the service of a political cause.
Sofie Gråbøl, born 1968, is one of Denmark's best-known actresses, skuespillere, and has played several lead roles as somewhat insecure, awkward people.
She became truly known in the 1986 film version of Tove Ditlevsen's novel Barndommens Gade in the lead role as the 14-year-old Ester, who grows up in Vesterbro in the interwar period.
Ester feels caught between childhood and adult life.
Between, on the one side, the working class's hard living conditions and the expectations of women at the time, and on the other side the dream of breaking free of the known world and becoming something greater.
In the film Der kommer en dag, from 2016, which takes place at a sadistic boys' orphanage at the end of the 1960s, she plays the teacher Lillian.
Lillian wavers between loyalty to her employer and her wish to fight for the boys.
When you talk about Sofie Gråbøl, the TV series Forbrydelsen, "The Killing", from 2007 to 12, cannot be avoided.
The crime series became very popular, not only in Denmark, but also abroad.
Here she appears in the role as deputy chief inspector Sarah Lund, who is to solve the murder of a 19-year-old woman.
Millions of people sat in front of the TV screen and guessed along who the murderer was.
Another of Denmark's most acclaimed actors is Trine Dyrholm, born 1972.
She has among other things taken part in Hævnen, where she plays the role as Marianne, whose husband has been unfaithful, and whose oldest son is bullied at school.
The role as the wife who feels let down by her husband also recurs in Kollektivet, from 2016.
The free-spirited Anna is, in line with the 1970s' ideals, sceptical of the nuclear family and a supporter of free love, but wakes up to reality when her husband falls in love with a younger colleague.
Another highlight in Trine Dyrholm's career, and another film about broken ideals, is Dronningen, from 2019, in the role as the lawyer Anne, who works with commitment to defend children and young people against sexual abuse, but throws her own morals overboard when she seduces her 17-year-old stepson.
Here is your recap for Episode Nine, and for Chapter Five.
Dogme 95 was a manifesto from 1995 by Lars von Trier, Thomas Vinterberg, Søren Kragh-Jacobsen and Kristian Levring, for simple films focused on the story.
Lars von Trier's first dogme film was Idioterne in 1998, and he won the Palme d'Or in 2000 for Dancer in the Dark, with Björk.
Thomas Vinterberg's Festen won the jury prize at Cannes in 1998, and Druk won an Oscar in 2021.
Gabriel Axel was the first Danish director to win an Oscar, in 1988, for Babettes Gæstebud.
Bille August won an Oscar and the Palmes d'Or for Pelle Erobreren in 1987.
Susanne Bier won an Oscar and a Golden Globe for Hævnen in 2010.
Mads Mikkelsen won best actor at Cannes in 2012 for Jagten, and played in Casino Royale in 2006.
Jesper Christensen starred in Bænken in 2000.
Sofie Gråbøl was Ester in Barndommens Gade in 1986 and Sarah Lund in Forbrydelsen, 2007 to 12.
Trine Dyrholm was in Hævnen, Kollektivet in 2016, and Dronningen in 2019.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which Danish film won an Oscar for best international film in April 2021?
Option A: Druk.
Option B: Festen.
Option C: Idioterne.
[DA] Hvilken dansk film vandt i april 2021 en Oscar for bedste internationale film?  A: Druk  |  B: Festen  |  C: Idioterne
The answer is A: Druk.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Druk
Question 2.
For which film did Gabriel Axel win an Oscar in 1988?
Option A: Druk.
Option B: Italiensk for begyndere.
Option C: Babettes gæstebud.
[DA] For hvilken film vandt Gabriel Axel en Oscar i 1988?  A: Druk  |  B: Italiensk for begyndere  |  C: Babettes gæstebud
The answer is C: Babettes gæstebud.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Babettes gæstebud
Question 3.
Which film director won an Oscar for the film Hævnen from 2010?
Option A: Erik Balling.
Option B: Carl Theodor Dreyer.
Option C: Susanne Bier.
[DA] Hvilken filminstruktør vandt en Oscar for filmen Hævnen fra 2010?  A: Erik Balling  |  B: Carl Theodor Dreyer  |  C: Susanne Bier
The answer is C: Susanne Bier.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Susanne Bier
Question 4.
For which film did Bille August win an Oscar?
Option A: Pelle Erobreren.
Option B: Jerusalem.
Option C: Zappa.
[DA] For hvilken film har Bille August vundet en Oscar?  A: Pelle Erobreren  |  B: Jerusalem  |  C: Zappa
The answer is A: Pelle Erobreren.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Pelle Erobreren
Question 5.
Who directed the films Idioterne and Dancer in the Dark?
Option A: Susanne Bier.
Option B: Lars von Trier.
Option C: Lone Scherfig.
[DA] Hvem har instrueret filmene 'Idioterne' og 'Dancer in the Dark'?  A: Susanne Bier  |  B: Lars von Trier  |  C: Lone Scherfig
The answer is B: Lars von Trier.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Lars von Trier
Question 6.
What is Susanne Bier, born 1960, especially known for?
Option A: She is a physicist.
Option B: She is a politician.
Option C: She is a film director.
[DA] Hvad er Susanne Bier (født 1960) særligt kendt for?  A: Hun er fysiker  |  B: Hun er politiker  |  C: Hun er filminstruktør
The answer is C: She is a film director.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Hun er filminstruktør
Question 7.
What is Sofie Gråbøl, born 1968, especially known for?
Option A: She is an author.
Option B: She is an actress.
Option C: She is a painter.
[DA] Hvad er Sofie Gråbøl (f. 1968) særligt kendt for?  A: Hun er forfatter  |  B: Hun er skuespiller  |  C: Hun er kunstmaler
The answer is B: She is an actress.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Hun er skuespiller
Question 8.
What is Mads Mikkelsen, born 1965, especially known for?
Option A: He is an actor.
Option B: He is an author.
Option C: He is a musician.
[DA] Hvad er Mads Mikkelsen (født 1965) særligt kendt for?  A: Han er skuespiller  |  B: Han er forfatter  |  C: Han er musiker
The answer is A: He is an actor.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Han er skuespiller
That's the end of this part.
Well done.